(uptempo music)
- Ilana, what's the bleach
situation in a fridge?
Like, do you think that'll work?
- Okay, you can bleach it,
but you got to water
it down enough after.
It would be best if you
had one of the steamers
that they sell, like on HSN.
- This is so disgusting.
Bevers filled up
all of my tupperware
with this disgusting spinach
that has now all gone bad.
It's so gross in here.
I have to throw out everything.
- Dude, are you, are
you chewing something?
- Yeah. I got some
like old school gum.
It's so good.
- Dude, I--
- Check this out.
- Oh my God, the sound.
I can't deal with this.
- Are you kidding?
You're cleaning fake boobs.
I have an issue with that.
- Dude, it is like
nuclear waste.
You're gonna turn
into Alex Mack.
- Who's Alex Mack?
- From Nickelodeon.
She's like neon.
- Statistically, most
people enjoy gum.
You, out of everyone I know,
would like a oral fixation.
- Can you spit it out?
Honestly, that is so gross.
It's this like, cud.
(makes gagging noises)
Oh my God. (coughs)
(uptempo music)
- Ilana?